there are two ways to do this you can go
from part one or you can go from part to
part three falls out equally from both
of them okay just because it was the
most recent one I'm going to go for a
part two I know this okay I know this
right now I want an inequality at the
end I want an inequality at the end so
to get to an inequality at the end I'm
going to have an inequality somewhere
earlier on so i need to think about what
inequalities are true of this that will
lead me to hear hmm now there aren't
many things that I know about this
really okay I don't want to make any
statements about alpha because alpha
appears in the final inequality right so
I'm going to leave that guy i'm going to
solve for alpha as it were but I've got
a t2 and t1 here and I know some things
about them I know some domain
restrictions on t1 and t2 not many but
what can you tell me about them what
restrictions are there
trust me there are not many it's very
simple and it's staring you in the face
what can you tell me simple information
can when does this situation start when
am I at the origin I'm at time zero
right so tell me what happens before x 0
all point to this graph nothing happens
before time zero right so therefore i
can know that this has to happen after
time zero right and this has to happen
after time one which is also after time
zero okay so i have two inequalities
hear this and this that's pretty much
all I know but it's enough watch if I
know that T 2 is greater than zero then
I can make a statement about this entire
right hand side this that has to be
positive okay because that's time to
write but since I know that time one is
also positive right and the whole thing
I super positive to make the whole
fraction positive right you've got to
have a positive new murder and
denominator that's your only way you
either have both negative or both
positive but I already know this one is
positive okay so therefore i can say 1
minus cot alpha the denominator that has
to be positive you see where I'm going
here okay so what I said um this is
positive side inequality but this is
positive so a new inequality okay so you
might even like to say he are that's the
reason I'm invoking and this is the
reason I've been working here okay now
i'm almost there you see you see how I
got rid of my t1 by t2 now I just need
to get to my alpha how do I do it let's
simplify a little bit shy 1 minus 1 so
i'll take that minus 1 over the problems
i divide through by negative 1 which
means what i did in your quality it
changes direction right
okay so far so good but don't forget
what is cot cot is 1 over tan right okay
now look at this this is tricky you know
where you're going you know where you're
going so what do you need to say about
this hmm if I take the reciprocal of
this side right and I take the
reciprocal of this side what happens to
the inequality it also changes direction
but why think about it for example if I
have some numbers that I do something
about ok 1 over 2 that's a bad example
sorry let's do to it I'm free okay if I
take the reciprocals of both sides 2 is
less than three but a half is not less
than a third make can you see why taking
the reciprocal is just like multiplying
by a negative it makes you switch this
thing around ok so I'm going to do that
here 10 alpha is greater than 1 what
does 10 offer look like no fun I know
what time looks like that's a sorry
excuse
and so on ok so what standards can i'm
everett this this is um 10 off his red
one here's one right here what value
corresponds to one for FR its pilot for
isn't it ah there we go okay but of
course I don't want values of alpha
greater than PI on too so I already have
a restriction in there on alpha right so
i can say don't ya okay I'm now between
pine for and pie on too because i know
that this had to be less than planned to
in the first place otherwise i'm
shooting in the wrong direction there
you go okay was that hard I'm not sure
it's kind of yes and no isn't it let me
know the maths of this is not difficult
they're very simple functions it's not
like a an algebraic mess like this is
but I think some of these steps in here
are conceptually more difficult to do
okay now by the way just as a point of
curiosity what does this mean like what
does this resolve this inequality sorry
what's that tea what does this
inequality mean well let's consider this
I'm considering a whole bunch of
different firing angles and different
velocities and so on okay well if I want
to hit this point here right where the X
and the y distances are the same okay in
other words I'm going through I'm going
through y equals x how can I do it right
well the other ways you can do it is if
alpha route between these angles right
think about it you know this means
here's here's a way to hit this point
there you go i go through that point now
what was it called I didn't have a name
did it HH okay I go through there right
if I have a lower angle that's still
okay I'm
there if I had a really high angle
eventually I'll get there ok so long as
I'm between Pro and foreign plan to our
somewhere intersect with this line ok
but number one if I'm greater than
planned to ok well it goes the other way
sorry ok but if I'm less than pine for
what happens the firing angle is too low
no matter how hard you fire it right you
know you're going to do something like
this or you find harder you get like
that like that like that you'll never
actually get up to that line does that
make sense ok so whenever you get a
result whether it's an inequality or a
particular value or something like that
if they don't ask you your choice
question well what's what's the
significance of it right its application
the calculus to the physical world ok so
that's that result